un gros de la pro a de volley
n'ira pas en finale du
championnat de france 2009
le tours volley-ball reçoit ce
soir le paris volley en
demi-finale aller
ce matin dernier entraînement
pour les deux équipes honneur
aux visiteurs paris choc le
parquet de la salle renaud
la puissance de feu des
parisiens en particulier au
service est connu ce ne sera pas
le pari qui a mis fin à la
série d'invincibilité du tvb
après dix journées
ce ne sera pas le parisien qui
au match retour affaiblie par
les blessures
à ce stade la compétition avec
la formule des play-offs tout
est remis à plat elle
la première l'étape est le
mais aime
les pores pour nasri est avide
de vraiment exprès on a en a
bien travaillé tactiquement on
a en effet précisé que man
il faut être à la hauteur ce
soir surtout après avoir battu
à son copain de promo mais pas
pour les plus motivés que tout
le territoire
les membres silver aux plus
motivés que nous relations une
demi-finale pour tous les deux
et e
séquencer c'est quand même
bien joué ici ces nouvelles
salles avec hambourg pour lui
un nouveau joueur et pas des
moindres est entré dans le
collectif parisien pour jouer
les play-offs en france après
une saison difficile en italie
hubert henno a été appelé en
remplacement délicat le poste
de libéro l'ancien joueur du
tvb retrouve gros noms dans
l'équipe d'en face qui ont
déjà content parce que je
voulais jouer contre toi c'est
normal
cette création a récemment
recommandé de ne pas pouvoir
jouer donc
je suis vraiment content de
pouvoir recourir au nucléaire
des moments été atteint
mais surtout des erreurs le
match vraiment super super sympa
le chiffrement contente
savoir plus sur cette voie
le dernier mot ce changement
trois grosses ambiances sonores
à 11 heures les volleyeurs
tourangeaux entre en piste
après la séance vidéo
ultime revue du jeu parisien
pour laisser un minimum de place
au hasard
on les a vus plusieurs fois pour
cette année même temps on a
joué à l'envers et lorsqu'il
jouait contre d'autres équipes
pour compenser exactement ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire
résonner les autres là c'est
juste une concentration unique
il est à craindre que la
stratégie d'orange comporte
aussi quelques temps
le niveau de motivation des
joueurs pour leur forteresse une
motivation pas difficile à
trouver pour les deux équipes
car même si avec la formule du
7 ans nord au match retour à
paris ce match aller de la
demi-finale de la demi-finale
le collectif victorieux
s'octroiera un ascendant
psychologique certain pour
samedi et si c'est le tours
volley-ball ça fera un bon
souvenir à guillaume quesque
qui fête aujourd'hui ses 20 ans